conservative mp sir desmond swain
in november last year speaking to save
our rights uk
a group that's advanced false claims
about the coveted vaccine
and organized anti-lockdown protests the
topic of discussion
the risk posed by the virus to the nhs
but it seems to be a manageable risk
particularly given the way that figures
appear to have been manipulated
um you know we are told that there is a
deathly
a deadly pandemic
proceeding at the moment that is
difficult to reconcile
with there is no evidence of figures
being manipulated and at the time of
this interview deaths were 14
above the five-year average according to
the ons
january the 15th this year and so
desmond is giving another interview
it is my absolute honor and pleasure to
be inviting uh sir desmond sweeney
to uh the high wire right now this time
it's to del big tree
leader of an anti-vaccination group and
former producer for disgraced anti-vaxx
medic
andrew wakefield where he's asked about
the uk's latest lockdown
is there some other desire to control
the people it has nothing to do with
health where are you at with that
there are aspects of this which i'm
certain come down to social control
uh like the wearing of masks the medical
case
you've just rubbished it several studies
have shown face masks can reduce the
transmission of viruses
hello desmond yeah hello hi it's rob
powell here calling from
sky news on a political correspondent
siddesman swain wasn't available for an
on-camera interview
but agreed to this phone call being
recorded on dell big tree did you know
who he was before you gave the interview
so he was someone that's anti-vaccine
and has said that the covert vaccine
could be the greatest scientific blunder
in the history of mankind again i state
you know having a conversation with
someone
is not in any way associating yourself
with his point of view you're lending
the credibility
of a member of parliament to some groups
which have views
uh which are not backed up by any
scientific evidence
well i i i you know the point is this
we're a democracy we've been
believing free speech and free
expression but those who track anti-vaxx
content online
say sir desmond's comments will cost
lives people of course have been
confused by
um a new pathogen a new disease which
has emerged
it's caused a lot of concern and to see
a member of parliament
feeding off that concern feeding
the feeding the bee so to speak is
incredibly cynical
incredibly damaging and will cost lives
so desmond sway the former minister in
the commons today
where a valid debate will continue about
easing restrictions
but at such a perilous moment in the
pandemic many will question where
and how this tory mp has chosen to have
this discussion
rob powell sky news in westminster